- Welcome back everybody.
Jennifer Garner is here with us.
Give it up.
(audience cheering)
Our next guest is an
NFL Hall of Famer
and you can see him every week on
Thursday Night Football, on Prime Video.
(swoosh sound)
- It's shocking to me
that you were even able
to play in this weather, but you did.
What was the experience like here?
- You know, coming out to the
Frozen Tundra at Lambeau Field?
I remember playing out here, but you do.
I had everything on back then,
but I remember looking,
I scored this touch
and I was like, hey, I turned around and
I'm telling that guy, don't touch me.
Don't touch me, because that ground hurts.
But honestly, I don't even
remember scoring this touch.
That's how much the
cold gets into my mind.
(audience cheering)
- TNF coverage begins at
7:00 pm Eastern, tonight.
Please welcome, Tony Gonzalez.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
- Yeah.
Alrighty.
- Well, welcome to the show.
So, from that video,
you are not into cold.
You don't like being cold?
- No, I hate the cold.
I hate it.
I'm a California boy.
You know, I was born and
raised in California.
Went to Berkeley, which was still nice.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And when I got drafted to Kansas City,
I was not prepared for...
Like, I always called it,
I have a condition, it's called Tropical.
(people laughing)
I like tropical weather.
Warm... but I get, it gets to my bones.
I'm just not into it.
- Oh my god, I love it so much.
- [Tony] Do you really?
- I do too, I love the cold.
- Do you really, you
love the cold weather?
- I'm so happy, when it's cold.
- It makes me so... it feels
fresh. Like a new start.
- Oh, I can't stand it.
I remember when I went to Kansas City,
it was the first winter,
I've ever felt, like,
really one of, almost the
first time I ever saw snow.
And I go out to my car
and we had this freeze
and the windshield was frozen solid.
And it's got... you can't see through it.
So I'm like, what the hell am I gonna do?
What do I do?
And so, I didn't know
anything about an ice scraper.
I didn't know you had
to have one of those.
So I was like, you know what?
I'm smart.
I'm gonna get a glass of
warm water, hot water.
- Oh no.
- And I'm just gonna pour it on there
and it'll melt the glass,
melt the ice right off.
Boom. Put it on there.
Crack the windshield and everything.
I was like, oh.
But that was my first lesson
into how to deal with the cold weather.
- I never really thought about that.
I mean, I guess in Texas
it... There's extreme cold,
I feel like, and extreme
heat. So I like...
- This in Kansas City.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, so during the winter it's frozen.
- That's why I don't like heat.
That's, I can't take my skin
off, you know what I'm saying?
But like, you can like,
put clothes on and stay warmer.
- Not on a football field.
- No.
- So you were in Kansas City pre-Taylor.
- Pre-, yeah, oh...
(audience laughing)
- Well, same position.
Right. Same thing. Same team.
- Same team.
- Did he just break your record, Kelce?
- He broke my record.
- Do you have to be bringing that up?
- Oh, no...
(audience laughing)
No, because you tweeted about it.
You did something about it.
That's how I know.
- Yeah. Well, Travis Kelce...
- You said congratulations.
- I said congra... Of course.
- Yeah.
- He's such a good dude,
and the whole Taylor Swift thing now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Is becoming to... I was
in the airport the other day
and this ten-year-old
girl, comes up to me,
and I don't, you know, men
usually come up to me, football.
- Yeah.
- And occasionally
like, you know, a woman,
but a ten-year-old girl,
I was like, oh, how cool.
I'm getting so popular
that a ten-year-old girl
comes up to me.
She goes, hi, is your name Tony?
And I go, yes, it is.
You know, like maybe (indistinct)
she goes, do you know Travis Kelce?
And I'm like...
(audience laughing)
- But, I think it's great.
- My god.
- That Taylor's done this for the NFL.
She's brought a whole new
audience. It's been great, yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I will say that, that is true.
And there's a lot of Swift'ies
out there watching now.
But I will say, and not because of that,
but I really got into football this year.
Like, I finally, I
think I just broke down.
Because all my friends
and family are into it.
I'm literally an alone on an island.
But I am obsessed.
Like I'm in Fantasy Football League.
- Oh, I was going to say.
- I love...
Do you do Fantasy?
- I do Fantasy. I do it with my boys.
My boy River and Nikko.
We're in a little league and stuff.
- Oh yeah, we both have a
river. I forgot about that.
- Yeah. We've got the river.
- Yeah, that's right.
Oh my god, I'm obsessed with,
I almost wish I, are you into football?
- I really like football.
I really do.
I really like marching bands. So I like...
(audience laughing)
- Is that not cool to admit?
Wait, are you kidding me?
The Ohio-Michigan game
and how the Ohio comes in.
- It's cool.
- Right.
- Wait, I literally just
lost my mic pack on that.
I like... No, I got Rosa.
I'm putting it back on. I'm so bendy.
Okay, so wait, talk about
Thursday Night Football.
What is the show like? It's kind of crazy.
It's not just football.
Y'all get fun on that.
- Oh, we do.
It's like a variety show sometime.
I mean, we do it, well
the pregame show is pretty
traditional, like a pregame show,
we get you ready for the game.
What to expect, what not to expect.
We have some segments,
Marshawn Lynch is on there.
I don't know if you guys know who he is.
He's pretty crazy.
He'll do a couple... Where
he, he'll go to like a bar
or go to a restaurant.
What else do we do, after the game though?
It's really cool.
That's where we bring on,
like, the player of the game.
So like, Darnay Holmes will be on set.
- Yeah.
- We'll shower bazooka brats.
- [Kelly] Why not?
- How many can you catch in 30 minutes?
So it's like more fun
and you're at the game.
So, the energy, it's electric.
It's just a lot more fun.
- I love that. That seems so much fun.
Okay, well before we
do a commercial break,
we got Tony a special
Kelly Clarkson show merch
to keep him warm.
(person laughing)
This is for you.
Happy Holidays.
- I love it.
No matter what it is.
- Happy holidays.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my goodness.
- And now, I literally
watch you all the time.
I was not into Football before,
but now I catch everything.
I'm even like the NFL plus girl.
Listen, you're going to look so good.
- Can I wear this?
I'm gonna wear this on the set next year.
- You should wear it.
(audience cheering)
- Alright everybody, watch
Thursday Night Football,
every Thursday starting
at 7:00 pm Eastern.
Only on Prime video.